each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay I'd like to welcome you to this
talk today and for the two of you that
don't know who Robert Scoble is I'll
read a brief introduction Robert is one
of the world's best-known journalists
Coble is best known for his blog Scoble
Iser
which came to prominence during his
tenure as technology evangelist here at
Microsoft currently he's the startup
liaison for Rackspace the open cloud
computing company Scoble travels the
world looking for the latest
developments on technologies
bleeding-edge he's interviewed thousands
of executives and technology innovators
and reports for Rackspace TV and in
social media and I'm thrilled to have
him here I know all of you are too so we
look forward to hearing him talk about
the age of context
let's welcome it's a big honor to be
here it's been a while since I've been
back at Microsoft I'm sorry you know
Rackspace asked me just go and study the
future and and to put the put that
learning up online and write books and
stuff like that and it's a fun job it's
a real a lot real honor so the book came
out of a bunch of conversations I had
almost two years ago now so the book is
starting to need a little bit of an
update cuz since then beacons have come
out and looked we'll talk about some of
the newer stuff I've seen I've seen but
I started seeing five trends that were
all happening at the same time and what
was really interesting is these five
things are fusing together to make a new
kind of software possible and the first
trend was sensors we just are seeing an
explosion of sensors on us around us you
know I'm wearing a sensor on my wrist
there's seven sensors on your phone some
of the phones have now have nine or ten
sensors my nest thermostat has a couple
sensors in it my Dropcam is really a
sensor every time somebody walks by my
front door my phone has a notification
and on and on
and the second trend was the amount of
wearable computers was exponentially
growing these are this is a guy up in
Vancouver who makes the in the guts of
the Oakley air wave ski goggle
he runs recon instruments which has a it
shows you where on the mountain you are
how fast you're going the hang time of
your last jump there's a sensor in this
thing and there's a screen here it's
pretty cool
the basis watch is a wearable with a
heart rate sensor underneath it so it
can watch your sleep pattern it knows
whether you're really exercising or not
which compares to this one which just is
studying motion and then we have the
Google glass which we can spend some
time talking about later and two kids
from Stanford put a HD video camera
inside the sunglass frames and they're
pretty hard to recognize that you're
being videoed add on to that the data
about our location is is getting sharper
we were just talking about Cortana and
how it compares the Sirian one of the
real feature benefits is that it it can
do stuff as you move around the world
because it knows the context of the
place you're going past you know if
you're going near a hardware store maybe
your app will say hey it's time to go
and pick up that screwdriver you put on
your to-do list you know kind of thing
and the amount of data socially is
growing exponentially you know when I
when I worked here at Microsoft eight
years ago
Twitter didn't exist Facebook barely
existed was for college kids and today
we are seeing Twitter has half a billion
tweets and it's going up exponentially
so that alone when you see exponential
numbers you know that businesses can
start or thrive on that and we'll talk
about a few businesses that are built on
top of that and then I just keep seeing
a bunch of database innovation partly
because the data center is changing from
hard drive based data centers to SSD
based data centers partly because the
cost
are coming down on data centers and
partly because the data flows are just
getting so extraordinary I just
interviewed yesterday the CTO from
SunPower which puts solar panels all
over the globe they have and they're
already getting 50 million sensor
readings from solar panels a day from
around the world and the data flows are
getting crazy and so you know Oracle is
not the way you're gonna build your data
sent data system for that so when I
started talking of seeing these five
things each of which needs its own book
I mean there's books on big data there's
books on social I wrote one when I
worked here at Microsoft called eight
called naked conversations and there and
so on and so forth but when I sat down
with several execs at Google and other
places they said there's a something
happening where the software we're able
to build is changing because of the
computer we're carrying in our hand so
Facebook just bought this company called
moves I don't know if any of you have
used moves but it already knows whether
you're walking running driving or biking
just based on the sensor patterns so you
know this lets us do a new kind of
operating system particularly one if you
have the data of what's on my calendar
and you have the data of what's in my
email you can build a new kind of system
that assists you as you go through your
life so let's talk about some of these
products that are coming along and and
what it means for us as human beings
what I'm seeing is products now are
becoming highly personalized and the
Oakley ski goggles is a great example it
has my ski data you put it on and it's
not your data it's very personalized to
me and when we visited Oakley they were
saying well you know we're gonna build
products that are gonna be custom for
you custom 3d printed custom data and
and the product is going to change based
on you this on what you're using it for
what kind of conditions it's gonna be
sensing etc etc this company is really
interesting
it's called tapingo or tap and go and
how many people have heard of
before yeah how did you hear about it I
saw the problem in Whistler okay so yeah
so this is for college kids right now
when I worked at Microsoft eight years
ago we kept hearing about this thing
called Facebook and we could never use
it because it was only for college kids
and we know the rest of the story there
if you're at Santa Clara University you
used tapingo to buy everything you buy
your coffee in the morning you buy your
sandwich you buy your books you buy
everything on it already 70% of all
transactions done by students are going
through tapingo and they're taking up to
10% cut of each transaction it's pretty
crazy
this came out of Israeli intelligence
the guy was doing surveillance work in
the in Israel at the time and he said
you know when we're doing surveillance
work in the military we're looking for
somebody who is out of pattern you know
if I go and buy a ton of diesel fuel or
a ton of fertilizer and a 800 gallons of
diesel fuel I'm out of pattern I don't
do that very often
and so somebody else probably come and
visit me right because like what are you
doing with a ton of diesel feed or a ton
of fertilizer and some diesel diesel
fuel he said this is switching it to the
other way which is I'm looking for when
you are in your pattern so when you wake
up at 8:00 in the morning on a Monday
morning and your first class is history
101 or whatever it says would you like I
slap your normal iced latte on the way
to class because it knows what you've
bought every Monday for the last five
Mondays and it's starting to recognize
your pattern in life and it's trying to
assist you when you order it the order
goes into a virtual queue so they'll say
your drink will be ready at 8:23 when
you went when you do that it sends the
order into a box that's in the Starbucks
or whatever coffee place you go to the
box lights up and beeps and spits out a
receipt which goes into the workflow
of the restaurant you don't when you
when you go to pick up your drink you
don't show any ID because they know
you're there because your phone is there
and we can talk about that and how that
can be sensed and you don't pay cash you
don't pay it charges you like uber you
know when you take an uber ride it
doesn't don't pay any cash and so that
this is seeing some pretty remarkable
things already and they just got eight
million dollars from Vinod Khosla let me
just back up here for a second see all
right well there was a Scully motorcycle
helmet there too but yeah
so the second thing that we're seeing
for humans is um we're gonna see new
kinds of anticipatory services and
products that you know Cortana is a
great example where where when you're
next to the hardware store and you've
told your to-do list that you need a
screwdriver it reminds you of that fact
because it knows something about the
context of the place and it knows some
of your intent so this is a tempo dot ai
and this is a calendar app on the iPhone
if I remember right and I think they
have it on Android as well it looks into
your calendar into your email this came
out of s RI where Siri came out of and
looks out on the internet for stuff so
one day on my calendar I just put
Flipboard didn't put anything else and I
found all the e-mails back and forth
between me and Mike McHugh at Flipboard
and it also found the correct address
which they had just moved to a new
office two weeks before that so that the
apps themselves are trying to assist you
by looking deep into your context Google
now is a great example of this if you've
never played with it it starts doing all
sorts of fun stuff based on what's on
your calendar where you are I think a
steam you were at one of my talks where
it actually tried to take control of the
TV in the room right that's pretty crazy
right now it's like you're next to this
team you would you like to put some
pictures up it's like wow that's pretty
crazy
and why is Google buying nest and buying
Dropcam well they want to be the default
place you go to interact with the people
around you the places around you and the
machines around you and Google now is
doing that there it's trying to get
ahead of you and trying to predict what
you need to do next and it's trying to
help you for businesses we're seeing two
shifts because of this new contextual
world businesses are being asked to see
everything about everything that the the
solar panel guys was a great example
they're building contextual systems to
understand what the sensor reading means
and they're comparing the context of
Internet data like weather patterns to
know what's going on on the solar panel
that's out in the middle of the desert
so is it dirty if it is it sends a
little robot over to clean the clean
that section of solar panels right it's
pretty cool and I I talked with Siemens
ahead of Rd and the power grid itself is
contextual so it knows pretty much what
to expect onload tomorrow because it's
already predicting what the changes of
temperature and changes of let's say a
Seahawks game might change the the
pattern of usage of power and I'll get
up for tomorrow's power demand
appropriately which makes it cheaper to
buy power because if you can predict
what you need it makes cheaper General
Electric is putting sensors into jet
airplane engines to understand when
they're and when they need to be
repaired Union Pacific's putting similar
sensors underneath the railways they
were seeing 40 million hits a day off
those sensors to understand whether the
cars need to be repaired and so and so
forth does the second impact that we're
seeing on businesses that we're gonna
need deep insights to our customers and
I've talked to Brits and we went to
Aspen and quite a few places that talked
about this
so the Ritz
it's a funny example did you know when
the Ritz started a hundred years ago
they used to have a room where they had
index cards on each of you and they
would go 300 years ago they used to go
through your trash looking for things
that you would throw away like candy bar
wrappers or apples or trying to look for
they're surveilling you they're just
spying on you trying to figure out what
you what you like to do and therefore
they'll have that waiting on the pillow
the next time you come back to the Ritz
this was a hundred years ago right today
they don't know Allah that's tough
because there's four computers at our
it's one that runs the spa it's a spa
finder computer one that runs the main
restaurant that's a open table computer
one that runs the main restaurant I
believe that's an IBM computer and they
really don't talk to each other very
well and they certainly don't know they
don't know anything about me which is
very apparent when you start tweeting
from the back deck of the Ritz they have
a social media team that listens to
anybody who says Ritz on Twitter or
Facebook and they get back to you in a
couple minutes
so if you're tweeting and from the Ritz
they'll say oh thanks for coming to our
party and have it and hope you're having
fun but if you start having a
conversation with them they go tone-deaf
very quickly they don't know we're on
the property I'm sitting they don't know
what my favorite drink is they don't
know who I'm sitting with and I talked
to the directors of marketing and we
predicted in the next five years they're
gonna know and I'm gonna know a lot that
they don't today I talked with a CEO of
a big oil company up in Canada he's
building a loyalty program to just for
this to understand his customers better
and to be able to serve them better when
they come into an establishment so let's
talk about some of the businesses
they're popping up this is a prime cents
sensor apple bot prime cents last year
for I think more than a million dollars
right and the Kinect sensor is based
loosely on the technology that was
invented here I think you guys licensed
some of the technology from prime cents
for the sensor the sensor so sensitive
by the way
well you guys know this you work it with
Kinect but they did a demo where the
sensor was up here aimed at a table with
and it could tell how hard I was
pressing the table and it was letting me
do pressure sensitive writing on the
table right so here they have a sensor
over your head and the sensor is so good
it could tell when your hand is heading
toward a box of Cheerios and I got a
demo of this at CES last year so this is
our a 18 months old technology and it
saw that I touched the box of Cheerios
it's that I pulled the box of Cheerios
off the shelf in real time and it had a
display here and it was changing what
the display was telling me based on what
I touched or pulled off the Box off the
shelf it's pretty crazy and that's what
it's doing here they're mostly using
this for analytics right now because
there's so much privacy concern on what
this stuff does but it's not too hard
for me to conceive of a world where a
beacon in your pocket will be used to
put a name on this guy and add it to
your shopping cart and on and on and on
and let's talk about so this is a shop
perception it's a company name that's
building this for Walmart down in Brazil
testing it out this is shelf box they
one demo god of the Year last year this
has a bunch of little radios in it
it's you're gonna have 20 of these in a
grocery store you're gonna have an app
that like the safe way up on your phone
you're gonna tap in to one of these
displays your phone is gonna tell you
what you're looking at so if you're at
the cookie aisle for instance you tap in
and it says oh you're a valued member of
Safeway and you can save two dollars on
a boxes where he goes right now or you
know hey I put on my on my bucket list
you know or my intention list that hey I
want to lose weight I don't want to do
carbs so it's gonna suggest now get out
of this IO and we'll give you some
incentive to go to the other aisle it's
something like that right and I can tell
that you're there by the way you don't
have to tap into it if you have a modern
phone you do if you have a cheap ass you
know flip phone kind of thing
but if you want if you it has nine
radios in there and it can see your
iPhone going through the aisle so it can
do if there's 20 of these in a store you
can track somebody going through the
store and you can change the offers
based on whether they've been to the
milk already or or not and this this
company's called bin tank it's a company
in Napa California they they use all
that Twitter data to see what you are
saying about wine in real time so if you
say I love Chardonnay it's it's putting
you into a database and building a
profile on you just by one tweet and
they're seeing 1.1 million tweets a day
about wine that we are all doing about
wine
probably half of those are coming from
Steve bro back right Rove AXA runs the
dent conference he's right here so
they're starting to put geo fences
around the wineries now and think about
what you could do in terms of
understanding customers based on this
data so let's say you own the camus
winter that's pretty good winery $200
bottle generally right and let's say you
own set her home that's $10 a bottle
you're far richer than that guy but your
wine sucks and let's say Curtis goes to
Napa and says I want to go to Napa well
if if Curtis goes to camus and tweets I
met Camus I just bought a case of their
reserve red well I know he just spent
$300 a bottle on on a case of wine when
he comes in to my place I'm gonna take
him right to my reserve room and tried
to talk him out of some more of that
cash that's in Islam right but if you go
to Sutter home and you say man I'm
having a great time drinking the
Chardonnay here I know you're drinking
the $8 $9 bottle that Marx who is
different kinds of customer I'm gonna
take you a different kind of place in my
winery this is already happening without
technology if you go to castelo de
Morris a winery in Napa there's a sign
are you
Patong
are you an Instagram user are you a you
know do you take pictures and if you do
tell the clerk well if you tell the
clerk you're on a different tour then uh
and then my dad is for instance because
my dad doesn't take pictures he's not an
instagramer and they have a photographic
tour of the winery because they know
you're a brand ambassador that you're
gonna share the visuals of that castle
that they built so yeah they're doing
all sorts of fun things and vin tank is
hardly the only company that's studying
us in this new way that they're
cataloguing us with this new public data
of social media that didn't exist back
when I worked here let's talk about some
of the toys that are coming along these
actually shipped after the book this
just shipped this month so this pre new
stuff
these are bluetooth smart beacons the
press calls them ibeacons because
Apple's marketing is pretty good but
they're not that's not an ibeacon the
beacon is a piece of hardware that's
made to Bluetooth specs so you know lots
of our phones have bluetooth how many
people have one of these here which ones
in what do you have yeah so that's the
middle one there are about 30 that so
these are $30 each retail if you buy a
bunch of them like if you're a Walmart
you need to buy thousands you can get
them for under $10 probably even close
to $5 they last for about two years on a
coin battery this is Microsoft so this
is gonna be an interesting answer how
many people have an iPhone with iOS 7 on
it whew you're all carrying a beacon and
you don't even know it it's probably not
turned on because the software hasn't
been turned on but if you have a newer
app like highlight that turns on the
beacon and so the beacon spits three
numbers into the air every every second
and if I have a phone like an Android or
an iPhone that I can see this beacon I
can know how close I am to you so let's
say we went drinking tonight and we're
sitting around for an hour and a half in
a place well now the system would know
where
in close proximity Facebook could a new
version of Facebook could ask hey why
don't you friend that guy I think it's
not on your friend list but you're with
him so he probably is a friend right
it's a suggestion right and it probably
can auto check us in sort of like the
new Foursquare swarm is doing and we're
gonna see a lot of these things
the newer sports stadiums are getting
these all over Sacramento Kings put
thirty five of these up Apple actually
paid for all the baseball stadiums to
have I think up to sixty in a stadium so
as you walk around with your phone the
the the phone the app that you're
running will show you different
information based on where it in the
stadium you are and possibly even who
you are with so they're already planning
on ticketless entry to the stadium's
navigation contextual meals coming you
know hey it's seventh inning and you
always get you know a hotdog delivered
do you still want that sort of like the
tapingo thing etc etc I bring in cars
and other things in the book we talk a
lot about what's going on with the car
this is my friend Annie who owns a Chevy
Volt
the Chevy Volt has I think a hundred
sensors on it and generates I I think
two hundred megabytes per second of data
most of that data is thrown away right
at the point of truth of capturing it
because it's running an airbag sensor or
a fuel sensor but some of that day is
stuck around the car itself is changing
to be an API and you guys know this but
the the the fact is the the cars are
biggest wearable computer we got right
and our phone is going to interact with
the sensors in the car and do things and
Mercedes just announced a contextual car
at CES this year and it's going to know
whether your kids are in the car so if I
say I need Pizza if I have an executive
in my car that's gonna mean something a
little different than if my kids are in
the car right because if if Curtis and I
want to go to Pizza
we want to go to a great pizza and not
you know some place where there's a lot
of kids right and they showed in
lifetime how the system can switch based
on the context of weather driving
conditions who's in the car our requests
and and other things and goods all the
way up to self-driving car I've
interviewed the guy who built the lidar
on top David Hall at Bella dine and all
the way in and talked to the guys who
run BMW it's a little bit off topic for
the book but it really is a contextual
system it needs to know what's coming
ahead so that it can respond
appropriately Waze is a good example of
this ways just the other day it really
saved saved my bacon because it started
warning me there was bad traffic ahead
and I turned a turn on the freeway and
it was just dead stop and if I hadn't
been paying attention and I didn't have
Waze yelling at me
God knows you know and this is how
accidents happen secondary accidents
based on dead stop traffic on a freeway
the self-driving car can know that from
the contextual systems that we're
building and predict that it should
start slowing down going around the turn
so it doesn't have to do a panic stop
mobile is changing how we approach
cities you know when I grew up my dad
never wanted to live downtown San Jose
because that's where the poverty was it
was where the crappy grocery stores were
it was where the crime was we just
visited Curtis Wong's office he was
showing me all the crime statistics in
Chicago on a surface computer was pretty
cool should see his demo if you haven't
seen it yet but now my son wants to live
in a city it's changing into a new we
call it a new urbanist and we identified
several new several of these people who
want to live in cities and I think it's
partly due to the services that are
available in a high urban density
neighborhood for instance I have an
office in San Francisco
my house is in Half Moon Bay California
which is about 45 minutes away I can't
get over in my house I can't get
instacart deliveries of groceries I
can't get ebay now you know if I'm in my
studio and I lost my Apple power supply
because I left it up here on the table I
can have one delivered to me in less
than an hour right in San Francisco but
I can't in Half Moon Bay and the
government now is getting on the mobile
phones right so if I see a pothole or a
problem I can talk to the talk to the
mayor you know where the or the system
and report that right so the the city is
getting smarter and more fun to live in
and the services are outstripping the
suburban neighborhoods and it's causing
a shift in our society which I I find is
fascinating I think I put a drone video
in here just to be gratuitous geeky but
this is my new DJI drone drones are our
turning contextual 2 because they need
to understand how to get back to home
how to fly around things their Apple
computer it is building this new
headquarters and they have a drone that
sits on a robot that changes its battery
and its memory card and then sends it
back up and lets it see the process of
building this headquarters so they have
a time-lapse off their drone but they
also can see in real time almost real
time how the trucks are coming on and is
everything moving smoothly and do they
need to make any adjustments in the
workflow of building this new building
and it's pretty interesting it does
bring into light another privacy problem
which I'll talk about in a second we
should spend some time talking about
wearables on the face that I I wore a
Google glass for a year last year and
I'm not wearing one obviously and I can
talk to you about why but it has a lot
of deep flaws for consumers around
change of social contract you know
there's a piece of glass between
and it lights up and I have to look at
it and you can't see what's on it so it
bothers a lot of people and I couldn't
figure out what was bothering him and
they kept saying you're recording me I
know that you can see that I'm not
recording it's the social contract that
changes and I wanted to fold up I can't
fold it up so they're fixing some of
that oculus rift is an interesting
product if you haven't put it on yet you
can you put it on and and you see this
3d world and you move your head and the
sensors change what you're seeing and
it's really immersive Mehta is a company
that's sort of melding both ideas
together into a very futuristic pair of
glasses it has a front-facing 3d sensor
that's that builds a new model of the
world as you look around it so it can
lay user interface elements or games on
the floor or change the floor or put a
stripe on the floor whatever you want
you know this software so you can play
around with the real world now it's a
augmented reality and it has to 720p
screens and I think a front-facing
camera and it's pretty interesting the
problem is this is still too heavy too
expensive and it's three four five years
out I think you know this year and next
year is pretty much gonna be about this
and maybe sensors in shirts and shoes
this is a little bit further off glass
is going to be used in vertical markets
I think but all of these are are really
contextual contextualize errs the Google
glass is the first consumer electronics
gadget that knows where I'm aimed and
can change the what it displays I use
this app on my phone called home snap
and if you use home snap you take a
picture of the house that you're looking
at and it tells you the MLS data tells
you how much it's sold for and all sorts
of fun stuff just because it knows where
you are and where you're aiming doesn't
really need the camera at all but
right because it just needs the GPS data
and it needs to know the the plot of
land that you're aiming at and it can
display stuff to you and usually after I
give my talk we have a deep conversation
about privacy that are you all freaked
out at all by this world where I mean I
go back to the cars do you know the data
that the Tesla is studying on you if you
turn it on so you saw this when the New
York Times give it a bad review they
drove it from I think boss New York to
Boston and the reviewer said oh I ran
out of power two-thirds of the way
through or something like that and had a
picture of it being towed away and give
it a bad review and Elon Musk said well
let's talk about the data and he had
proof that the guy had done doughnuts in
the parking lot and that he had turned
the heat up all the way and other things
and in other words we're heading into a
world where we're always gonna be
surveilled I mean we're all holding
phones right and that sensor already
knows whether it's in your pocket or in
your hand
I've seen this software or whether
you're walking around with it it changes
on the screen say you're walking around
right now because it can sense that
you're working you know so the sensors
are already able to give it a lot of
contextual data plus all the stuff that
I mean there's a camera back there
that's watching us and it's being
translated to 35 languages or something
like that thanks to Skype right right I
mean it's crazy the world that you guys
are building
I assume that we're gonna do it and
we're gonna do it cuz there's gonna be
utility and at this point I usually ask
people how many don't use credit cards
is there anybody here who doesn't use a
credit card yeah I don't think so
it's very rare that somebody raises
their hand says I don't have a crack art
that's the largest gifting of private
information to a public company and
we've ever done far more than some of
this stuff will do and we do it because
we get deep utility for doing it
we're protected against being robbed and
we get free credit or credit then we pay
a lot of money for and I think this
stuff is gonna be the same way these 3d
sensors are gonna shrink down to the
point where they're gonna be in your
phone or in in a gadget right and we
know that because this is the guy who
runs primeSense
and he showed me a stick of gum and
that's the new sensor and that was a
year and something ago a year and a half
ago already so imagine what they're
doing at Apple to make that thing
smaller and what you guys are doing in
your labs to make the Kinect sensor
smaller and soon it's going to be in
glasses and in walls and advertising
you're gonna walk by an advertising sign
it's gonna follow you around well your
your thing right in your lab you you
move around and it's watching where you
are and changes the data on the screen
right this cool but it comes at a
cost of it's able to see your face in a
far deeper way than just a little 2d
camera right I don't know where we want
to go with this so that that's usually
where I end up and have a conversation
about what else I'm seeing in the world
or what not but uh what do you guys
think about this stuff are you are you
excited about this new world building
the big data systems like Curtis is
trying to well it for people who don't
know Curtis he has this visualization
system that he can put something that
looks like an Excel spreadsheet and
click a map and it doesn't map right of
that data and he lets you fly through it
it's pretty cool and you can see all
this satellite data on another product
you make it's pretty cool stuff what's
that yeah I remember well you know you
knew Jim Gray before he sailed out to
never be seen again but I remember when
he showed me the first terabyte the
largest database was that terabyte
tarah sir and today that seems pretty
quaint isn't it you mentioned a lot
about Twitter but if you look at the
statistics like a small fraction of the
world just we take these for granted but
which we really don't see is both a
selection bias of all the things that
haven't happened oh yeah and because
whom look at retrospectively at the
things that haven't happened and also we
sort of it's hard to tell like which one
is a mass market versus between the land
of being totally it's hard to tell
that and big companies are you know I
remember having arguments when I worked
here at Microsoft you know should we pay
attention to social and the answer then
was no from Billo directly right and
maybe that was a mistake
300 million people today are on twitter
and 1.3 billion people are on Facebook
that's a pretty nice number I think
Microsoft likes those kinds of numbers
there's finally starting to affect
they're finally starting to get to the
numbers that you know that moved the
needle at a company like like Microsoft
I assume that if there is utility that
people will adopt and I am seeing
utility and better calendars and better
shopping systems and Amazon right Amazon
published our book when you buy just one
book off of Amazon it starts
recommending all sorts of other things
because it puts you in a queue with
people like you who bought that book and
the suggestions are so good you know and
that's stuff that's five ten year old
technology it's it's not really mind
blowing new contextual technology on
your mobile phone using sensors to study
me in some new way right yeah do you
think this is actually changing things
that much or is it more bringing it to
the broader market like your Amazon
example that was available a long time
ago to the publishers where they had all
these ala date of what books were
selling us who they would actually
choose as their authors so they'd be
what was available for purchase rather
than saying buy this
I should get much different than what's
going on before I think it really is a
change you know talking to the Google
has a contextual operating system team
it's like future future version of
Android and they they really say it is a
shift in how you think about software
because you know when Microsoft started
out it was put a computer on every desk
right and the computer never moved and
you didn't need to write software that
reacted and changed based on what it was
next to and who it was with and what
kind of sensor reading it's seeing as
it's being moved around so that's that's
a pretty big shift I think it's a pretty
big shift and and startups like moves
give you a little taste of what's coming
I saw a camera company that just uses 2d
cameras and just Lipstadt faces and
already can tell your age plus or minus
five years just by licking your face
with a 2d cheap-ass camera net no Kinect
you know kind of sensor and I can tell
your gender and I can tell your
emotional state at SSRI as I saw another
system where you just read 200 words off
of a card and I can already tell about
70% of time whether you're suicidal or
not but but you think about the
emotional experiments that Facebook's
been doing trying to see how how
addicted do you get if I show you 10
happy posts instead of 10 sort of sad
ones this is it's a new level of
software that's mixing social with
sensors with with big data insights like
what you guys are working on at
Microsoft Research
you know yeah as an author and changing
the subject just a little bit what is
your perspective on the pricing pressure
on you know these content delivery
mechanisms have on the industry you mean
oh that's interesting
you mean from a book publisher stamp
yeah how many of the people who bought a
book in the last
who bought it on Amazon yeah I asked
that question two years ago and that's
why I give up my book is not available
at Barnes & Noble or on bookstore
shelves unless they buy it from Amazon
and here's my first book was published
by Wiley we've already made three times
more money even though we sold about
half the copies so for a book published
and for a book author this is a good
thing
plus I don't need to deal with
committees
I hate committees Thank You Microsoft
for teaching me that lesson
I hate committees and I hate bureaucracy
and with my first book if I wanted to
give you a free copy I would had to
convince a committee that it was worth
giving you a free copy of my book and in
this world
it's my book I can give you a free copy
costs $5 right and if you buy it it's
it's a 20 bucks with the old world you
only got a paper copy today you know you
get a Kindle and an audible audible and
Kindle by the way are two-thirds of the
sales of the book so 1/3 is paper most
most people are buying electronic copies
and that audible I don't know if you
knew this but I didn't know this before
I published this book if you read to
page 59 on Kindle and then you go in the
car and start listening to audible it
picks up on page 59 and starts reading
yeah it's very cool it syncs up and you
know I'm a competitor of Amazon but
they're smart people and yeah you have
some questions it's a question from
online will there be a dominant context
aggregator or can we expect each company
to develop their own private profiles
well we're in a if we're in a siloed
world right now I mean my nest
thermostat has data on me
my Dropcam even though it's owned by the
same company doesn't hook up to that
right I assume it will I assume Google
now is gonna be the aggregator for the
Google data but there's still a lot of
shoes to come and wearable things and
things on your wrists and soon we're
gonna have oh yeah oh yeah I took out a
slide there's gonna be a health pack
sauna soon you know I've visited an R&D
lab in Dublin or in Cork Ireland that
makes silicon-based needles and I put my
finger on it felt like sandpaper
but the needle goes deep enough for your
skin to pull out a few cells of blood
and do something with it like test it
for glucose level or whatnot so you can
imagine you're gonna wear a little thing
like this that's gonna do all sorts of
stuff at SR I they have a sensor that
today is this big that senses whether
you have pancreatic cancer out of a few
cells of blood right and so we're gonna
you know ten years from now we're gonna
wear things on our on our skin that are
gonna tell us whether we're having a
heart attack tomorrow whether we have
seriously there's sensor coming that
tells that that looks at certain
chemicals when your heart gets under
stress it's going to warn you that
you're gonna you need to go to the
doctor now wait good chunk of the
population will get hurt yeah I have two
friends who have had quad bypasses right
and they were lucky enough to get to the
doctor in time the hours do matter in
some of these situations right and
having a sensor that's what I'm saying
there's gonna be deep utility to doing
this stuff it might save your life it
might tell you you need to go see a
psychiatrist if you're if your words are
coming out suicidal right like that card
did right yeah I really love all the
concrete examples you gave kind of like
you know here's location-based sensing
you can understand what wineries you've
been to and market to them accordingly
right yeah for the camera at the end you
know understanding facial expressions
that
you know more broadly speaking
automatically understanding every detail
of what's coming up the cameras and
looking for pictures online actually
mean what do you think the utility will
be and what did some in the fall that
we'll see or engine well and the first
one is marketers gonna use it to figure
out how to arrange stores to maximize
their profits let's just be honest but
we're gonna use this kind of data to
understand the Facebook newsfeed right
take that emotional experiment to the
next level if I show you a happy poster
you actually smiled you laughed it
doesn't make you have an emotional
reaction in your face if you read
something about Gaza right now does your
face change I bet it does and so it
could feedback that that information
that you didn't even click like or
dislike or hide it your face showed it
so it could make the feed better it
might we should spend a whole hour
talking about facebook my facebook looks
completely different than most of your
Facebook it's yeah let's pull it up you
know I mean we do have the internet here
you know but most people's Facebook
feeds are full of memes and stuff like
that well here you know here's Jason
taking a picture of me right there
but here's Scott Jordan CEO of the guy
who made my shirt antony mcgregor day is
married to the social-media VP at
IndieGoGo Alex fielding as a friend of
Steve Wozniak's and is running a few
really interesting companies ok Lincoln
Park I like Lincoln Park they like me
too
Alex feeling again Paul Mabry is the CEO
of that vin tank company Twitter just
doubled its revenues he said so that's
look like that yeah
Teresa Valdez Klein would who's a friend
of three of ours at least is there the
verge George kleeger
I forget who he does it what he's a
photographer Sam 11 runs PR for JBL so
my feet is very different and has a lot
of tech on
a lot of tech news most of the time
where most of my friends feeds are full
of memes and cat photos and cute videos
and stuff like that because that's what
they click like on they trained the
filters to bring them more things to
addictive more right so yeah this is
already turning contextual in there and
this is not one algorithm running this
fee there's hundreds of algorithms that
are looking at popularity sentiment what
might actually be in the content is
there a person there is there a happy
person right because if they did their
emotional research properly they know
how many happy posts to put in here to
addicted thing and make me click refresh
again instead of going back to my normal
life you know right right yeah can you
talk about adoption patterns for some of
this technology so you had tempo for
example which i think is a great app but
is failed in the App Store and do very
well at all there are a lot of companies
and products that you and a lot of
people in this room would be jazzed by
but the general average user just
doesn't care
same thing with your Facebook I don't
agree with you there I I sat at a
concert and I sat next to an insurance
salesperson from Chicago he did have new
no clue who I was and he was like poking
on an Android phone and then I strike up
a conversation I mean he's like have you
seen this thing called Google now I go
yeah yeah it is cool and I'm gonna feed
it more data because it it keeps getting
better the more I tell it about myself
I'm like you're an insurance salesperson
in Chicago because you just said exactly
what the Google executives would have
said at their product launch right he
already got it and I think the world is
gonna get now I don't know who the
winner is gonna be I mean if if we go
back to when Bill Gates was building
basic compilers even he didn't know he
was gonna run the world of operating
systems because he want he sent IBM
twice down a DRI research to get CPM
from this little company down in Pacific
Grove and they
big big mistake but I don't know who the
winners are gonna be this is early days
I mean yeah the stuff I'm seeing on
Facebook newsfeed is it's just giving a
little taste of what it'll be like in
ten years right yeah steep Robert can
you come we've learned in 18 months on
expectations our own privacy or what's
changed and specifically yeah yes I I
think both but I don't know if I knew
those answers I'd start a company where
I'd I'd come back at Mike's after and
run a product yeah because you know
snapchat for instance has gotten popular
and when I talked to kids about why cuz
I go to Coachella and see people on
different social things and I'm like why
do you use that
well I there's drama on Facebook that's
how they talk right what do you mean in
bad drama well if I click like on the
wrong persons the wrong persons post
then my that then the other girl who
goes why are you liking her post you
know I have that drama at home right
what why are you clicking on that girl's
feet all the time yeah yeah so so
snapchat took advantage of a need to
remove drama and consequences from
social behaviors online because the post
disappears so the other girl can't see
it for very long if it can be seen at
all right
and so the so there are product
opportunities on both sides I think
there's there's a new digital divide
okay there is a new digital divide not
between people can afford technology and
can't like we talked about for 30 years
but between people who are all in like
me and that insurance sales person and
people who are all out I had dinner with
Richard Stallman and he's wearing a
button that says pay cash for everything
stay off the grid
no Facebook you know in other words and
don't beat on this company everything
about you yes it'll be used against you
and we can talk about how how it's being
used against you but there's a risk to
all technology right I'm that new
digital divide is going to there's going
to be a lot of people on both sides and
so you can design a product for the
people who are all out and there's
plenty of examples of companies that are
doing a new very private skype type
thing types of things like silent circle
and then there's lots of products that I
think are gonna go what I call it going
over the freaky line that are gonna
bring utility in a new way and ask
people to give it a lot more data I have
a feeling there's more money on over the
freaky line than on this side but I
don't know if I knew those answers just
definitively be building a company I'd
be building a company here so I mean you
go around you give this talk to our live
presumably tech companies didn't talk to
a lot of people do you find that people
on average you're sort of more excited
or more fearful or is there a sort of an
even split
you usually when I talk to the regular
audience is about third of the people
raise their hand when I when I say are
you freaked out so this stuff freaks
people out but then I ask who's gonna
use Google now and and almost all the
hands go up right because there's you if
there is utility I think people are
gonna go there there is gonna be a
period of friction where we argue about
it and we resist it because we're scared
of media scares us I'm seeing this all
the time on Facebook that people have
locked down their privacy too much and
it's hurting them but they don't know it
and they because they're freaked out by
the media reports and and their friends
say no you've got to take off your
location off of Facebook or oh you got a
you know lock down your privacy so
nobody can see your page you know stuff
like that it's you contextual absolute
services using
that's a big question
so the question was what are my favorite
contextual apps other than Google now
you know I'm seeing a context in a lot
of weird places like a human is an app
coming out in a couple weeks that you
put your contacts into and yeah other
things and it starts telling me oh this
guy's next to you what you know why
don't you say hi and it also encourages
you to join it which gets my contact
list updated pretty cool i tempo i I
actually like tempo because if there's a
conference call it tells me the pin
number and I just can click on it I
don't have to type it in stuff like that
and it tells me a lot of data know what
Starks I write because I don't have that
it tells you it's going to read in two
minutes
oh it's a dark sky is a weather app that
tells you it'll rain in ten minutes if
you had an expensive convertible yeah
that would be a it's good yeah and the
micro weather now is getting really good
and it as more and more sensors get out
more and more micro weather can be
reported back to because our behaviors
change as weather happens let's go back
here yeah I'll get to you I think one
thing you were talking about was like
trust sharing data yeah you feel a big
word yeah like with sharing all this
data do you think that it's I should be
putting my trust in these companies soon
yeah yeah Trust is a big word and Ford
CTO used that word he because we were
talking about Tesla and all the data
that they're collecting and Mercedes
contextual car and he says you know I am
really freaked out by this world and I
think my customers freaked out you know
Andy green on and him caught and calm
you know NASCAR fans or you know Joey
bag of donuts average person doesn't
want their car surveilling them when
they go to a church or a strip club or
whatever right and I said there's three
things a company needs to do to earn
trust in this world the first thing is
you need to be transparent on the data
you're collecting Google actually does a
pretty good job of this there's a data
privacy dashboard if you do a Google
search Google data privacy dashboard
you'll probably find it it shows
everything Google's collecting on you
and it's a pretty long list so kudos on
Google on point number one I think you
guys do similar stuff with being in
other places where you're collecting
data second thing is you need to make
the data correctable I used to use a app
called sage which was like a Google now
competitor and it kept telling me all
sorts of stuff about golf you know it
turns out I live on a golf course I'm on
a golf course a lot I hate golf
and I don't ever want to see anything
about golf I don't want to know about
golf deals I don't want to know about
the golf pro the teaching a class I am
NOT interested so shut up because it's
and the fact that I can't make it shut
up makes me trust that system less than
if it had a way for me to correct the
data and say yeah I live on a golf
course but I don't like also stop
showing me Goffstown and the third thing
is if you're wearing one of these my
wife lost 40 pounds with a fit better
right this is an accelerometer with a
clock and if you have the basis one with
a temperature sensor a perspiration
sensor and a heart rate sensor so that
when I interview the CEO of basis I said
so basically you know when I'm having
sex don't you and he goes no I can't see
that data and I'd like yeah but it's
there and so is there gonna be a
consequence of me of collecting that
data store a wait shell Israel wants to
turn it off for a couple hours you know
just say don't study me I disagree with
him I think I want to
be studied in my life but I don't want
the consequence which is why snapchat
popped up and it solves often a
multi-billion dollar company because
there was a consequence of doing a
behavior and the kids are like uh we
don't want that consequence so we're
gonna build another system that we can
still talk with each other without the
consequence so the guide those my shirts
by the way he has a transmission proof
pocket so you can put your RFID you can
put your phone in there and it stops
transmitting you won't get any phone
calls because a Faraday cage kind of
thing and I gave a talk at Maker Faire
in New York and a kid in the front row
said yeah I'll rebuilt one and he had he
had already built something so he can
hack the system and stay out the grid
and and control the consequences of this
always surveilled world so I I think
we're gonna be we're gonna be in a weird
place for a while where we're trying to
figure out the consequences and figure
out how to change stuff like that yeah a
fundamental difference between the web
to companies sort of like Oh God like
like automatic who built WordPress or
there's a whole range of them yeah
versus this new new company I think the
major differences these are people these
are companies coming out of people who
think about mobile all day long and
think about the world of mobile that's
going to be around them they're people
like Tony Fadell at who built nest right
he came out Apple the iPhone team right
and he understood mobile at a deep level
and he understood how to make a
beautiful great product that people
would buy and he created a lot of value
very quickly
I think the next generation is going to
be people who are adept at fusing data
from multiple places and doing stuff
like what Curtis is doing to visualize
it or have a feature pop up that uses
the fuse data to see something new in
the world right oh yeah differences in
valuations I think how do we put that in
96 I CQ came out November 1st 96 and it
took six weeks to get to 65,000 users yo
just came out and yo got to two million
users in a few weeks so the speed at
which companies can be built is is much
higher than it used to be so the
expectations for investors on adoption
is higher but when you do get something
that gets adopted it gets adopted it's
such a fast rate that the valuations go
completely crazy really quickly Uber's
in a good example I've given speeches
all over the world and every audience
has had an experience with uber right
how many people have used uber here yeah
this is a worldwide brand that is a only
four year old brand right it's a company
that's only four years old and it
happened because of Twitter and Facebook
and Google+ and LinkedIn and and
snapchat because we can communicate with
each other and saying there's a hot new
thing right now try it out and so ideas
spread a lot faster than they did you
know in the 70s right when you were
mentioning about what's already
happening with the credit cards
I talked to privacy with other friends
where tech savvy or whatever and they're
saying you know the room is getting so
scary yeah and I say well imagine a
world where every time you go and buy a
video at Walmart Walt Disney is looking
through the tampons you bought and the
soap suds and what aisle you bought
everything from
I was my first job at Microsoft 21 years
ago working with Disney tracking that
data yeah it's not new we actually have
more control over it more awareness of
it now but this has been going on 1012
years ago you know what but what lean is
being or MSN tracking people's ads
versus what like the porn people and I
mean people on the city side we're
tracking so much information so that one
person visit one site that told them
they're interested now suddenly they're
getting all their ads coming up this
been going on for dozen speakers yeah
point is that Microsoft has been doing
this kind of contextual work for 20
years
true in fact the the Google glass was a
thesis project in 1981 right by Thad
Starner I read his thesis paper it it it
delineate what Google glass is word for
word and was in 1991 so we've been doing
research that's pretty mind-blowing for
a long time it's just now it's in your
hand
we didn't 20 years ago you didn't have a
mobile phone that every single human
being is carrying around with seven
sensors on it and you didn't have a nest
thermostat next to it or a Dropcam or a
lockitron lock that's going to unlock
your locks Hilton just announced that
you're gonna unlock your locks with it
with phones right so that's what's
changed
and I think what's also changed as we
now have the data systems in place that
are so large and so fast that we're now
able to do real-time products that are
built on top of data right you know a
lot of them you well in the newsfeed
right I mean this is changing based on
what we're all doing together Waze is
changing based on what we're all doing
together it brought sus around traffic
if you're up ahead of me in an accident
it routes me around you all right and
that's a difference I'm not you know
when Jim Gray did the first tourist
server that was 1990 right terabyte that
was the largest database in the world
here at Mike's out in 1990 yeah so
things have changed
you've been doing the work but now it's
real and part of it is is that not just
Microsoft the tools the world has been
silently mining all this data for years
and people didn't help who weren't aware
of what was going on and they didn't
have any control over it and they didn't
necessarily always benefit personally
themselves yeah because it was used
against them and I think now the
contract of trust and productivity and
it is is different now oh yeah the
perception is there but in order to make
that you have to now have a relationship
where you're exposing like you said
transparency and and Trust because now I
go and I see that Amazon warns me that
this product is available from another
vendor at a lower price but if you want
Prime and today shipping you click this
button yeah now I can click the button
because I know I don't have to go look
to see if they're you know gonna gouge
me yeah so that let me see if I can wrap
it up for the people listening yeah your
point was just that there's now it's a
product Heysel thick the data is a
product I zibethinus in our hand I know
that it really is a big shift one last
question what who have the last to be
signing books and yeah we have books in
the back and I'll send them up front
let's get one last question in the back
yeah yeah quick question for you
in the PC market we've seen certain form
factors play out and others not so much
for examples netbooks are there certain
form factors or I guess technology
platforms that you think will be more
abundant or do really well and then also
what is it for you the pricing is going
on it's so first thing what do you mean
that form factor are you talking about
like a watch or a glass or wearables
like fitness trackers or there's certain
categories
smartwatches that you're more bullish on
pricing yeah where are a few history I I
think the whole industry is going to
reconfigure around whatever Apple
announces on the watch if the Apple
watch and there's a reason for it if the
Apple watch sucks the whole industry is
going to change its belief about itself
and as
a market differently if the Apple watch
if I get it and it's amazing the whole
industry is gonna have to readjust
around that right because Apple owns a
lot of the influencers and a lot of the
rich people and they're the ones who are
going to decide on on how important this
is
I don't know I I can I don't know you
know I I heard hints my some of my
friends have seen it and said some say
it's amazing some say it sucks I don't
know I have to see the product and have
it on my skin for a week before I'm
gonna really have an informed opinion
about that and then the market is gonna
do what its gonna do
pricing is always going to come down the
guy at Mehta
right now the meta glasses cost about
$3,000
he can't that company came out of
military just five years ago those were
a hundred thousand dollars so the cost
is coming down at a pretty significant
rate at Moore's Law rate and I half the
price every 18 months so if you can't
afford $3,000 wait 18 months it'll be
$1500 and wait 18 more months it'll be
$750 I'm waiting and then there'll be a
breakthrough and maybe it'll be $300 you
know so and also as the scales of these
of the sales go up you see economies of
scale where things get a lot cheaper to
produce
you know the beacons being a good
example of that anyways thank you very
much and I'll be around